comme la science et la vulgarisation
sont deux sujets qu'il convient de
traiter quand même avec beaucoup de
respect nous avons décidé d'arrêter les
blagues les paix et les jaunes mots on
n'est plus là pour rigoler aujourd'hui
nous allons donc aborder un sujet
complexe avec beaucoup de calme et de
[Musique]
respect sans transition aucune on va
vous poser une question comment fait-on
pour enlever un chewing-gum dans les
cheveux le cancer je vais vous poser une
question une question vous vous êtes
sans doute jamais poser d'ailleurs
qu'entre nous faut vraiment pas avoir
grand chose à faire de ces journées pour
se poser des questions pareilles de
quelle couleur est un atome le cancer je
vais peut-être répondre moi-même au
question aussi à première vue on a envie
de se dire bah de la couleur de l'objet
qu'il compose genre un atome de lingot
d'or c'est doré sauf que non les atomes
n'ont pas la couleur du truc qu'il
compos ils ont d'ailleurs pas de couleur
et quand je dis pas de couleur ça veut
pas dire qu'ils sont blanc gris ou noir
ils n'ont juste pas de couleur il est
tellement facile cet épisode quelle
performance de vulgarisation je suis
abasourdi oh tu sais c'est surtout avant
tout beaucoup de travail pourrais-tu
néanmoins approfondir oh la flemme non
et puis en plus c'est de la physique
j'aime pas ça ma prof de physique au
collège elle était horrible alors
approfondi humain où j'appelle ta prof
de physique de collège je crois qu'elle
a eu un vague problème de chewing-gum
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet de
la couleur de l'atome quelques
précisions s'impos d'abord c'est quoi un
atome un atome est un constituant de la
matière il est une entité électriquement
neutre composé d'un noyau et d'électrons
qui gravitent autour du noyau un atome
c'est tout petit de l'ordre de 10 pu- 10
m et très léger de l'ordre de 10 pu- 26
kg vous risquez donc pas d'en voir un à
l'œ nu d'ailleurs c'est tellement petit
que l'atome rentre dans le cadre de la
physique quantique et comme vous le
savez la physique quantique c'est le
bordel pour comprendre pourquoi les
atomes n'ont pas de couleur on va rester
sur notre exemple du lingot d'or déjà
parce que je suis vénal et que l'atome
d'or bah c'est ce qui compose le lingot
et puis ça parle à tout le monde un
lingot d'or sans surprise c'est composé
d'Atom d'or parce que de toute façon je
viens de le dire et un atome d'or quand
on regarde certains tableaux périodiques
des éléments il est représenté en jaune
mais en fait c'est pas vraiment jaune le
tableau périodique des éléments il
représente pas la vraie couleur du
machin en fait c'est juste une
représentation qui colle à notre
perception et qui nous aide à travailler
et d'ailleurs c'est pareil pour le code
CPK CPK qui signifie Cory polling culton
du nom de ses inventeurs heureusement
qu'ils étaient pas 14 le code CPK il est
utilisé pour identifier les éléments
dans les modèles en gros on a donné une
couleur logique aux atomes parce que ça
nous arranga bien puis voilà ce code
vous l'avez très certainement utilisé au
collège sans même savoir que ça
s'appelait comme ça l'hydrogène était
représenté par une boule blanche
l'oxygène était représenté par une boule
rouge le carbone par une boule noire et
cetera ensuite vous les assemblez et paf
ça fait des cosmopopes et paf ça fait
des molécules parce qu'on n pas une
chaîne de cuisine je vous rappelle
revenons-en à notre atome d'or dans son
noyau il y a 79 protons 118 neutrons et
on en a rien à secouer par contre en
orbite il y a 79 électrons et ça ça nous
intéresse bon faut savoir qu'en vrai un
atome ça ressemble pas à ça c'est trop
petit pour avoir une image détaillée non
mais je vous l'ai dit c'est dans le
cadre de la mécanique quantique on est à
une échelle subatomique là c'est
l'échelle à laquelle htman va sauver je
sais plus qui dans le film faut une
combinaison spéciale moi la mienne est
au pressing je peux pas vous montrer ce
qui nous intéresse ce sont donc les
électrons les électrons se trouvent
autour du noyau à des orbites très
précises ce qui veut dire qu'ils ne
peuvent pas Orbiter n'importe où et me
demandez pas pourquoi je vous ai dit que
c'était de la physique quantique
désormais si vous avez une question à
laquelle on ne comprend pas la réponse
dites-vous que c'est à cause de la
physique quantique c'est la réponse à
tout bonjour je suis Valentine de la
chaîne science de comptoir et j'ai une
question je vous écoute pourquoi le
conflit Israël palestinien physique
quantique bonjour je suis pH de la
chaîne LEP genous c'est j'ai une
question je vous écoute il y a ma meuf
qui s'est barré avec mon père vous avez
une idée de pourquoi vous êtes très prêt
monsieur quand un électron se prend un
photon dans la tronche alors un photon
c'est une particule élémentaire de la
lumière pour les buons physique et bien
quand l'électron se prend un photon
d'une longueur d'onde très précise dans
la tronche il gagne l'énergie du photon
absorbé on dit alors que l'atome est tu
excit bon du coup on a un électron qui
vient de se faire chauffer l'oignon en
conséquence il remonte d'une orbite avec
l'excitation de l'atome nonobstant c'est
tout et me posez pas plus de questions
je vous ai dit la physique j'aime pas ça
laisse-moi résumer ton explication
humain tu divagues trop un électron
reçoit un photon d'une certaine longueur
d'onde l'atome s'excite ensuite l'atome
se désexcite l'électron émet un photon
d'une longueur d'onde précise on appelle
cela le spectre d'émission de l'élément
sauf que le spectre d'émission c'est pas
de la couleur la couleur c'est ce qu'on
voit concrètement vous et moi c'est la
lumière blanche qui arrive sur un truc
ce truc absorbe certaines longueurs
d'onde en émet d'autres qui sont
interprété par notre cerveau dans le cas
d'une pomme rouge par exemple elle
absorbe tout un tas de couleurs et elle
émet du rouge dans le cas d'une pomme
verte par contre elle absorbe le rouge
et elle é met du vert parce qu'en soi
une couleur ça n'existe pas c'est une
perception sensorielle du coup dans la
physique quantique à l'échelle
subatomique il y a pas de couleur alors
htman dans son monde minuscule ultra
coloré c'est du bullshit et entre nous
j'ai pas vraiment de combinaison au
pressing donc la couleur comme on
l'imagine comme on la voit c'est pas un
truc qui colle avec la mécanique
quantique le concept de couleur n'existe
pas dans la mécanique quantique demander
la couleur d'un atome c'est comme
demander c'est quoi le plat préféré d'un
atome et pourquoi les cosmopops oui ben
moi j'ai déjà vu la photo d'un atome
d'or prise avec un microscope a fait
unnel et ben franchement c'était jaune
oui mais non sur cette photo là qu'on
peut pas vous montrer parce qu'on a pas
eu les droits du CNRS mais que du coup
vous pouvez trouver par vous-même parce
que bon fait un effort et bien on peut
voir des espèces de billes jaunes orangé
toutes les unes à côté des autres
tellement bien rangé qu'on dirait les
alvéoles d'une ruche sauf qu'en fait ça
c'est comme les photos des trucs qu'on
voit dans le ciel au télescope spatial
c'est pas les vraies couleurs cette
photo pas là on l'a recolorisé pour que
ça colle à notre perception de la
réalité on allait pas la recoloriser en
terracota et d'ailleurs c'est même pas
une photo cette pas photo là que vous
voyez pas parce qu'on a pas eu les
droits on devrait plutôt dire que c'est
une reconstitution d'Atom d'or et ça a
été fait grâce à un microscope à effet
tunnel ce genre de microscope c'est pas
un microscope avec une lentille comme on
avait au collège c'est une petite pointe
minuscule qui mesure quelques atomes de
large à son extrémité ça me rappelle
quelqu'un par rapport à sa cette
petite pointe elle va sonder la surface
de l'objet qu'on étudie et un courant
électrique va passer en entre les atomes
de la pointe et ceux de l'échantillon
c'est ça l'effet tunnel l'échantillon
lui au moins il a senti quelque chose
j'ai bien fait de partir avec son père
les variations du courant vont permettre
de faire une espèce de cartographie du
relief de l'objet ça va reconstituer une
image à aucun moment on va capturer de
la lumière dans le procédé donc on
colorise comme ça nous arrange et en
l'occurrence ça nous arrange bien de
mettre du jaune pour des atomes d'or
c'est grosso modo le même principe que
le braille vous passez votre doigt sur
les petites bosses et donc vous pouvez
lire parce que vous sentez des trucs ah
mais j'aurais peut-être dû lui apprendre
le brail voilà donc maintenant vous
savez pourquoi les atomes n pas de
couleur et pourquoi ils n'ont pas la
couleur du truc qu'ils composent et je
sais pas comment vous en êtes arrivé à
vous poser cette question mais vous avez
quand même pas grandchose à faire de vos
journées et comme vous avez pas
grandchose à faire peut-être que vous
pourriez je sais pas vous abonner et
puis bah merci parce que si on est sur
une saison 4 et ben c'est quand même pas
mal grâce à vous donc merci beaucoup
très non obstant néanmoins